u.s senator catherine cortez masto
visiting a clark county school today she
came to talk about the recent funding
coming from the american rescue plan and
how it will help
education in the state a news now
reporter kristen drummond live outside
of hancock elementary
with the latest on that story kristin
brian and denise senator cortez masto
coming here to see the first week back
with full
in-person learning at ccsd elementary
schools
she chose hancock elementary because
this is actually her alma mater but she
used this opportunity to reveal what
families can expect
from the recently passed covid19 relief
package
she says the state can expect to receive
roughly one billion dollars for k-12
schools
there's also 92 million dollars for
nevada to assist with covet 19 screening
and testing
superintendent dr jesus jarrah says more
than 800 million dollars of that 1
billion
is expected to help ccsd he says the
funds will support students mental
health continue closing the digital
divide and address equity gaps but
he does not plan to make any big
decisions without some feedback
as we continue to review the guidelines
we're going to have community engagement
conversations we have to have some i
appreciate the accountability that the
federal government has put in place
to make sure that the money goes to kids
to support
our students and our families and our
employees
dr jarrah anticipates money also going
towards professional development for
teachers
he says there's a lot of work to ensure
the roughly 18 thousand educators here
have the resources needed to give
students a high quality
education now dr jarrah also addressed
the low
enrollment for hybrid learning for
middle and high schools he says
this is a trend that his colleagues
around the nation are noticing in their
districts as well
but he says the focus right now is to
make sure students get the credits
that they need and using those federal
funds will help create a
summer accelerator program to help with
that
reporting live outside hancock
elementary school i'm kristen drummond 8
news now